plusieurs hôtes espérer que la
vaccination permettrait d'éliminer le
virus de lakovic 19 un peu comme on l'a
fait avec la variole ou du moins de le
contenir comme dans le cas de la
rougeole mais avec l'arrivée fulgurante
de micron qui déjoue notre immunité
durement acquises ces espoirs se sont
évaporés le consensus scientifique se
consolide le virus est là pour rester en
d'autres mots il deviendra endémique il
sera alors le cinquième coronavirus à
lettres aux côtés des quatre autres
corner virus qui causent les rhumes
commun la pandémie se terminera alors
non pas par une éradication du virus
mais par une transition vers une phase
endémique quand la maladie deviendra
moins mortel plus prévisible comparable
aux grippes saisonnières
de missile imminent
mais les experts les plus optimistes
suggèrent que cette transition pourrait
survenir dans la prochaine année
qu'est ce qui permet de déterminer le
passage entre la phase pandémique et la
france endémique du virus il n'existe
pas de critères scientifiques exactes ou
définition universelle selon cdc
américains un virus et 10 ans dit mic
lorsqu'il est présent de manière
constante dans une population avec un
taux d'infection relativement prévisible
et une circulation stable du virus pour
y parvenir la maladie doit atteindre une
forme d' équilibre avec notre immunité
collective s'impliquent que près de la
totalité de la population est une forme
d'immunité acquise par la vaccination ou
par une infection cette immunité serait
alors suffisante pour empêcher des pic
de propagation mais insuffisante pour la
stopper car cette protection seraient
contrebalancées par la perte d'immunité
causés par son affaiblissement dans le
temps ou par les mutations du virus une
perte qui permet au virus de continuer à
circuler une situation bien différente
de la situation actuelle dite pandémique
ou de vastes groupes sont encore sans
immunité permettant encore des flambées
de la propagation plongeant à répétition
les systèmes de santé dans la tempête
[Musique]
dans le dernier siècle nous avons vu
plusieurs pandémie faire cette
transition la grippe espagnole de 1918
après trois vagues mortel est devenue
une grippe saisonnière endémique encore
avec nous aujourd'hui il ya eu aussi le
sida et la grippe porcine ce sont des
malades y est avec lesquels nous avons
appris à vivre dont nous avons évalué
les risques et desquels nous savons
protéger les plus vulnérables pour les
gouvernements reconnaître que le virus
devienne rap endémique c'est cesser de
penser qu'il y aura une date de fin
c'est se préparer une transition vers
une gestion d'une vie avec la copine
de plus en plus de pays par d'une
transition prochaine vers une phase
endémique en particulier depuis
l'arrivée du variant au micron dans le
taux d'hospitalisation semble inférieur
aux variants précédent et qui fait
miroiter une situation un jour plus
gérable il a fait à grande vitesse la
population accélérant son immunisation
aussi à ses débuts le risque d'aider
c'est de là que vides étaient cinq à dix
fois supérieur à celui de l'influenza
mais avec la vaccination et l'arrivée
des traitements antiviraux les
scientifiques espèrent qu'on pourrait
réduire les risques de dessins de plus
de 90% par rapport à 2020 ce qui
pourrait abaisser ce risque à moins de
0,1 pour cent un niveau similaire à
celui de la grippe
l'arrivée de l'endémie se profile
l'espagne et le royaume uni ont su gérer
dans derniers mois considérés par ces
prochainement à une gestion plus adapté
à une maladie endémique se rapprochant
davantage de salles de la grippe
aux états unis des membres du groupe de
travail sur la gestion de la coved du
président bart hayden ont publié la
semaine dernière
trois articles scientifiques dans
lesquelles ils réclament la mise en
place d'un plan national pour mener
cette transition
[Musique]
mercredi en réaction à ces annonces le
ms mettait en garde contre une
transition trop rapide
y aussi le chemin vers la phase
endémique ne sera pas forcément direct
ou facile
rien n'empêche au cours des prochains
mois l'émergence de nouveaux variants
échappe à notre immunité plus virulents
opposants à nouveau des pics de
mortalité
ne
savons pas à terme de quoi aura l'air la
coved endémique sa sévérité sa
transmissibilité le rythme auquel n
échappera au vaccin certains spéculent
qu'elle pourrait un jour devenir aussi
binning que les coronavirus qui causent
rhume mais elle pourrait aussi continuer
à peser lourd sur le système de santé
comme la grippe saisonnière pandémique
depuis longtemps et qui pourtant est une
des causes les plus importants de
mortalité dans les pays développés
on s'attend donc en 2022 à ce que ces
discussions occupent de plus en plus de
classe comment et quand opérer la
transition comment se préparer à
cohabiter avec le virus de l'aco vide
comment passer de l'état d'urgence d'un
virus pandémique à la gestion d'un virus
pandémique
[Musique]